THAT.
>> YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Tucker: FOR ALL OF 20
16 AND SINCE THEN
HILLARY CLINTON HAS BEEN BEGGING
AMERICA TO JUST OF    FORGET ABE
AMERICA TO JUST OF    FORGET ABR
EMAILS.
IT'S BECAUSE THAT USE OF MY
EMAIL ACCOUNT WAS TURNED INTO TO
MAKE A SCANDAL AND LORD KNOWS
WHEN.
THEY COVERED IT LIKE IT WAS
PEARL HARBOR.
>> Tucker: THIS WEEK, CLINTON
APPEARS TO BE REVERSING THE
COURSE AND THE STRAIGHTEST WAY
POSSIBLE.
ON TUESDAY, SHE APPEARED AT AN
ART EXHIBITION IN ITALY.
DESTINATION FEATURES, OFFICE,
WITH THE PUTTING STAFF OF THE
EMAILS RECOVERED IN OUR PRIVATE
SERVER.
HILLARY CLINTON SPENT AN HOUR AT
THE EXHIBITION SITTING AND
READING HER EMAILS AND DECLARING
"BORING."
IT WASN'T BORING.
IT WAS WEIRD AS HELL.
THAT'S WHY WE PICK UP THE RED
PHONE AND CALL MARK STEYN.
BROUGHT THEM HERE TO EXPLAIN
WHAT JUST HAPPENED.
OR, WOULD YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> I THINK AS BERNIE SANDERS
SIDE, WHATEVER IT WAS, FOUR
YEARS AGO.
I'M SICK TO DEATH OF YOUR EMAIL
EMAILS.
THAT'S THE POINT, BY THE WAY,
THAT BERNIE LOST THE DEMOCRAT
NOMINATION.
UNLIKE TRUMP, THE LOW ENERGY
JOB, HE LIKED THE KILLER
INSTINCT.
I THINK EVERYBODY, -- I THINK
BERNIE'S RIGHT THOUGH.
OF THE DEMOCRATS ARE SICK TO
DEATH OF YOUR EMAILS.
SO HILLARY TURNING HERSELF INTO
A PIECE OF PERFORMANCE ARTS AND
GOING OUT TO THE VENICE OF ALLEY
IN ITALY AND SITTING BEHIND A
REPLICA OF THE OVAL OFFICE DESK
WITH EVERYTHING A PRINTOUT OF
HER EMAILS.
WE'RE GOING TO REMEMBER ABOUT
THIS, TUCKER, SHE ACTUALLY
CALLED THE VENICE AND TOLD THEM
I HAPPEN TO BE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
I DON'T KNOW IF I'M IN MONTE
CARLO, OR WHEREVER THAT WAS, AN
END I COME AND BE PART OF IT?
THAT SHOWS A WOMAN WHO SIMPLY
REFUSES TO GET OFF THE STAGE NO
MATTER HOW MANY BOOKS THEY TRY
TO PULL HER OFF WITH.
>> Tucker: IT DOES SEEM A
LITTLE STRANGE BECAUSE EVEN HER
HUSBAND, A MOSTLY        FAMOUSL
HUSBAND, A MOSTLY        FAMOUSY
HUSBAND, A MOSTLY        FAMOUSV
HUSBAND, A MOSTLY        FAMOUSD
AFFIRMATION, HE IS RECEDED FROM
THE PUBLIC VIEW IN EFFECT
RETIRED.
HILLARY CLINTON, YOU WOULD THINK
WITH HER GRANDCHILDREN.
WHY SHE DOING THIS?
>> I THINK -- I DON'T THINK SHE
HAS GIVEN UP.
SOMEBODY PICKING UP THE PHONE
AFTER A COUPLE MONTHS AFTER
DEBATE, JOE BIDEN IS SAVED SAGAN
DEBATE, JOE BIDEN IS SAVED SAGA,
LIFELESS, HE'S THE FRONT
RUNNER, NOT ENTHUSIASTIC.
HE'S EXACTLY WHERE SHE WAS 40
YEARS AGO.
AT THIS STAGE, HILLARY IS
DREAMING -- WE NEED YOU TO COME
BACK ABOUT HILLARY.
THIRD TIME'S THE CHARM.
WE ARE ALL DESPERATE FOR YOU,
WRITING FOR YOU.
IF SHE'S GOT THE BOOK OUT.
AGAIN, IT'S RELEASING THE START
OF THE PRESIDENTIAL SEASON.
SHE IS HAPPY WHEN SHE IS SUCKING
UP BIDEN'S AIRTIME AND BERNIE'S
AIRTIME.
AND ELIZABETH WARREN SAID, AND
THE 27 ROLE.
THAT'S WHY SHE'S DOING IT.
SHE'S FILTERING THAT'S ALL TO